j'aime bien ce bureau moi j'ai président
bonsoir bonsoir merci nous accueillir
avec arlette chabot les événements se
sont succédé depuis votre dernière
intervention télévisée le 20 septembre
dernier il y avait eu la grève qui a
suivi la réforme des régimes spéciaux de
retraite et puis il ya eu des violences
urbaines du début de la semaine donc
et puis évidemment il ya les attentes
pour ne pas dire les impatiences des
français sur le pouvoir d'achat
alors on va vous interrogez
chronologiquement peut-être sur ce qui
vient de se passer
le dire sur ces violences urbaines de
questions pour pour commencer d'abord
est-ce qu'elles ont été gérés par le
gouvernement de la manière dont vous les
auriez gérer si vous étiez à paris d'une
part et deuxièmement est-ce que deux ans
après les émeutes d'aulnay-sous-bois ce
n'est pas au fond une sorte de constat
d'échec
après tout ce qu'on allait annoncer sur
ce qu'il devait faire
la balle d'abord ils ont été très bien
gérée par le premier ministre et par la
ministre de l'intérieur françois fillon
et michèle alliot marie ou 10/10 j'étais
en chine oui effectivement mais enfin
quand on évoque ce parce que je suis en
chine que je ne regarde pas de près ce
qui se passe et c'est ce qui me permet
de vous dire que ça a été bien gérée
deuxièmement ces événements gelé j'ai
jugé d'une extrême gravité
je ne les prend pas à la légère du tout
et que des individus puissent tirer sur
les forces de l'ordre toujours des
fonctionnaires qui font leur métier sur
le territoire la république française je
ne peux pas l'accepter
c'est la raison pour laquelle à peine
descendu de l'avion je me suis rendu au
chevet de ses policiers blessés qui ont
été exemplaires de sang froid nous avons
eu 82 blessés
je pense particulièrement un
fonctionnaire de police jeunes courageux
qui a perdu un oeil
parce qu'un voyou lui a tiré dessus
autour de la tête
que la balle est passée sous la visière
je pensais ce commissaire de police
extraordinaire que j'ai vu avec sa femme
enceinte à ses côtés qui a été lynché à
coups de barres de fer et je veux dire
la façon la plus solennelle que j'ai
fixé un objectif de résultat
nous retrouverons les tireurs de la
police c'est pas une reine de la police
ce sont des individus qui sont des
voyous des structures et qui sont prêts
à tout qui sont des trafiquants
nous les retrouverons un par un et pour
eux ce sera la cour d'assises parce que
tiré sur un fonctionnaire ça s'appelle
un crime une tentative d'assassinât et
je ne suis pas décidé à accepter cela
nous avons vis mais tous les moyens de
la police scientifique et technique
les forces de police auront les moyens
qu'il faut le temps qu'il le faut pour
les retrouver ça ne peut pas rester sans
conséquences
je le dis d'ailleurs aux fonctionnaires
de police on est passé à deux doigts du
drame
j'ai rencontré l'un des policiers qui a
été blessé
18 plombs dans le corps un autre qui en
avait 1 loger sur la pommette et celui
ci m'a dit qu'il avait le tireur dans
son viseur il aurait pu dire et on
aurait pu avoir un drame
ça n'a rien à voir avec ce drame des
deux jeunes qui ont perdu la vie à 15
ans à la suite de l'accident de moto que
l'on connaît pour lequel j'ai d'ailleurs
demandé qui est une instruction pour que
la justice puisse passer que la vérité
puisse être révélé et pour que chacun
s'apaisent ça n'a rien à voir avec un
problème social
je vois pas au nom de quoi tirer sur des
policiers
l'alsh et un commissaire de police ça
amène en quoi que ce soit améliorer la
situation sociale et moi je ne répondrai
pas à cela en donnant plus d'argent ou
plus de moyens on donnera plus de
sanctions à ceux qui ont fait cela mais
cela via un plan qui est toujours prévu
et qui sera annoncé en temps mais
naturellement et
pas les dames à barra l'annoncera c'est
un plan qui sera fondée non pas sur la
rénovation des bâtiments
on a déjà beaucoup fait faut arrêter de
dire que rien n'a été fait beaucoup a
été fait et les français sont en droit
de se demander ce qu'on a fait notre
argent l'argent de leurs impôts
beaucoup a été fait ce qu'on fera c'est
qu'on investira au maximum sur les
personnes parce que moi je veux qu'on
soit plus généreux pour ceux qui veulent
s'en sortir avec un droit à la formation
pour trouver un emploi et pour vivre de
son travail et qu'on soit plus sévère à
l'endroit de cette infime minorité qui
se comporte de cette manière
un constat d'échec m'écouter qu'est ce
qui s'est passé pendant des décennies on
a fermé les yeux
il s'appelle simplement depuis quelques
années qu'on réagit la république ne
cédera pas un pouce de terrain
voilà ce que j'ai pensé de ces
événements voilà la réponse que nous
allons leur apporter
mais comme vous le voyez je ne prends
pas du tout cela à la légère mais quand
vous dites quand même on ce sont des
voyous effectivement qui tiers c'est
dangereux et effectivement qu'ils se
saisissent sans doute dans les studios
pour passer mais c'est quand même
toujours dans des zones où il ya des
situations qui sont quand même
extrêmement difficile il ya 20 30 40 %
de chômeurs dans cette ville il ya un
revenu moyen annuel qui est 6200 euros
par exemple on va rien fond de malaise
autour de ça qui est grave c'est une
circonstance aggravante s'agisse ici par
gare et on la pensait mort heureusement
arrêtons la pensée unique tous les
chômeurs ne tire pas sur les policiers
sur des gendarmes
tous ceux qui ont des problèmes pour
boucler leurs fins de mois ne trouve pas
intelligent d'aller mettre le feu dans
la bibliothèque au volant enfants dans
l'école où vont nos enfants il faut
arrêter maintenant avec cela la vérité
c'est qu'à des trafics
il ya les trafiquants il ya de la drogue
il ya des voyous il faut les traiter
comme des trafiquants et comme des
voyous j'ajoute que j'ai demandé aux
forces de l'ordre de faire une opération
systématique pour aller chercher les
armes
quant à l'hélicoptère a survolé certains
quartiers il a vu qu'on avait préparé
des parpaings des munitions pour jeter
sur les forces de l'ordre qui
que sa voix que malaise social faut
arrêter maintenant il ya des
comportements des lieux un billet à des
comportement inexcusable qui sont donc
inexplicable quand on veut expliquer
l'inexplicable
c'est qu'on s'apprête à excuser
l'inexcusable pour le reste ya un
malaise social
il ya une immigration qui pendant des
années n'a pas été maîtrisée des ghettos
qui ont été créés des personnes qui ne
se sont pas intégrés c'est la raison
pour laquelle le gouvernement met en
oeuvre avec mon soutien et à ma demande
une politique d'immigration choisie
c'est la raison pour laquelle les forces
de l'ordre ont des consignes de sévérité
à l'endroit des délinquants et c'est la
raison enfin pour laquelle madame fadela
amara qui j'ai toute confiance fera un
plan spécifique pour ceux qui dans ces
quartiers et ils sont l'immense majorité
veulent s'en sortir
comment elle a dit oui mais comment on
peut s'en sortir écouter on peut pas
s'en sortir si on va s'coucher chez soi
jusqu'à midi on peut pas s'en sortir si
on va pas à l'école on peut pas s'en
sortir si on n'a pas une formation et on
peut pas s'en sortir si on n'a pas la
volonté d'exercer un travail
c'est comme ça dans la société française
on peut pas s'en sortir alors on donnera
à chaque jeune qui voudra s'en sortir un
droit à la formation pour qu'il est un
droit à l'emploi
il faut maintenant que la république
soient plus généreuses à l'endroit de
tous ceux qui veulent s'en sortir
puis moi je pense à l'immense majorité
des habitants de ces quartiers mais qui
en ont plus qu'assez
c'est au les premières victimes ont beau
leur bus vous l'aimez piqué au nom de
quoi qu'est-ce que ça va amener à la
situation dans des quartiers qu'ils ont
déjà excentré on va leur donner à ces
gens qui habitent dans ces quartiers le
même droit à la sécurité que ceux de nos
compatriotes qui habite en centre-ville
ils ont le droit maintenant et puis il
faut qu'on retrouve un minimum
d'autorité yahoo si la paille et nous
mêmes quand vous étiez mis les
intérieurs mais malheureusement ab mais
les change pas monsieur prévert fort je
ne pense pas que ça change pas beaucoup
puisque désormais la république ne
recule pas pendant des années il faut
dire la vérité aux français
les forces de l'ordre honte éviter un
certain nombre de quartiers et on a
acheté une forme de paix en laissant les
trafiquants trafic et on peut faire
beaucoup de reproches
sauf celui d'avoir menti aux français
sur la gravité de la situation des
quartiers et comment pouvez vous penser
qu'on peut arranger ça qui est la marque
d'un laxisme de 30 ou 40 ans simplement
en six mois de présidence de la
république ou en quatre années de
ministère de l'intérieur où je n'ai
cessé d'ailleurs de demander des moyens
sur une nouvelle législation
et dieu sait qu'à chaque fois ça a
provoqué les cris d'orfraie je pense sur
les récidivistes
lorsque j'ai demandé l'accroissement des
peines pour les mineurs
multirécidivistes ne sais pas parce
qu'on lit mineur qu'on doit être impunis
je pense à bien d'autres cas j'ai aussi
ce matin
cette enseignante roué de coups par un
de ses élèves de 15 ans enfin souhaitons
c'est d'une gravité extrême
j'ai demandé au ministre xavier darcos
une enquête pour savoir exactement ce
qui s'était passé et pourquoi cette
enseignante remarquable par ailleurs
n'avait pas été soutenu comme elles
auraient dû l'être par l'encadrement
et qu'est ce qu'on va faire de ce garçon
de 15 ans c'est d'une gravité extrême
frappé son professeur devant les autres
élèves à l'intérieur de la classe on ne
peut pas l'accepter je n'accepterai pas
ça je suis également tient aujourd'hui
les parents de cette jeune fille
assassinée par un délinquant sexuel
récidiviste dans le rer
quand je vois et j'ai demandé à rachida
dati qu'il l'a fait avec beaucoup de
courage de faire voter une loi sur les
récidivistes ce monsieur avait déjà fait
une tentative de viol même un viol il
sort de prison
et voilà que la première chose qu'il
fasse c'est un dimanche matin cette
petite jeune fille de 23 ans prenait le
rer à 10h30 du matin un dimanche pour me
dire qu'elle prenait des risques quand
même il a fait la mauvaise rencontre
je le dis de la façon la plus claire je
demanderai au parlement sur le texte
rachida dati d'imposer une peine de
sûreté
après la peine de prison à tous
ces prédateurs qui tant qu'ils ne se
feront pas soigné ne sortirons pas de
prison mais ce sont des affaires très
sérieuse ou à chaque fois je dois me
heurter à une pensée convenue voit les
droits de l'homme auquel je pensais
d'abord cela victimes parce que chacun
d'entre nous ça aurait pu être l'un de
ses enfants et je ne banalise pas ces
choses et à ceux qui s'étonnent que je
reçoive les victimes
j'estime que c'est mon devoir de chef de
l'état que d'apporter pas simplement le
soutien mais de faire de ses victimes un
symbole pour que ça ne se reproduise
plus l'enjeu c'est que c'est une tâche
très difficile
je sais que ça demandera du temps je le
demande aux français
mais je le dis je me battrai sur ses
convictions sur ce droit à la sécurité
et sur la différence entre les voyous et
les honnêtes gens parce que c'est la
mission que j'ai reçu mes pensées petite
précision ce la police
petite question on sait toutes les
critiques qu'on les a entendu que vous
avez fait contre la police de proximité
qu'elle était en place par la gauche
laxiste etc
mais pour remettre un peu de lien entre
les policiers et les habitants de ces
quartiers je pense pas des jeunes en
général
est ce que vous pensez pas qu'il ferait
quand même une police affecté un certain
type de quartier où c'est une fois le
véhicule qui revient de la gauche qui
absolument un bélier selon suis pas du
tout parce que dieu ma gauche une
ridicule cette idée enfin on va voir ce
que le le brave policier dit de
proximité alors qu'ils étaient là aux
heures ouvrables aurait pu faire face à
des individus qui team qui tirent sur
les fonctionnaires
ça n'a pas de sens vers l'immense
majorité des habitants des quartiers se
plaignent pas qui est trop de police il
se baigne en a pas assez
qu'est-ce qui se plaint qui trop de
police
c'est ceux qui trafiquent à trausse une
police qu'on connaît agi sans penser à
la police qu'elle est quel est le rôle
de la police est pas qu elles
connaissent ces canards est et
délinquants la police n'est pas là pour
organiser les matchs de football ou
faire des relations publiques
il ya pour cela des travailleurs sociaux
des animateurs de clubs sportifs nova
revenons à des idées simples qui ne sont
pas simpliste pour le reste j'ai demandé
également la police pas plus tard que ce
matin de se garder de toute familiarité
avec les jeunes mais qui que ce soit
d'ailleurs
d'abord le souci de l'éthique et de
respecter les règles d'apple serait bien
mais je crains dire quelque chose
nous avons 80 de policier à l'hôpital
tous ces termes et on leur a tiré dessus
y'en a pas un seul qui a répondu je
crois qu'en ces périodes on peut quand
même se dire qu'on a le droit d'être
fier du comportement de la police
républicaine
deuxième gros événements de ces
dernières semaines les retraites avec
tout d'abord la réforme des régimes
spéciaux les grèves que l'on a vu est ce
que la prochaine étape maintenant c'est
l'augmentation de la durée des
cotisations pour tout le monde permettez
moi de dire un mot sur ces questions
parce que j'ai entendu beaucoup de
commentaires
d'abord et peut-être cela va-t-il vous
étonner je veux rendre hommage aux
partenaires sociaux
tous tous tous françois fillon xavier
bertrand et moi même on a travaillé main
dans la main tout essayé que le dialogue
puisse prévaloir mais je vais le dire
aux français
bien sûr qu'on n'était pas d'accord tous
monsieur thibault monsieur chérèque
monsieur mailly patron de la cgc la cftc
tour n'étaient pas d'accord sur tout
mais on était d'accord sur une chose
c'est qu'ils prenaient qu'on dialogue
j'avais dit aux partenaires sociaux que
je ne pouvais pas céder parce qu'il n'y
avait pas de raison que tous les
français cotisent 40 ans et que les
français des régimes spéciaux qu'otis 37
à l'ennemi c'était une question d'équité
les compensations vous les avez plein
sur ya des négociations elles se
déroulent
nous suivons ça jour après jour mais le
gouvernement et moi-même on a été
heureux de trouver des partenaires
sociaux qui ont pris leurs
responsabilités
alors je pense aux usagers qui c'était
la galère pendant neuf jours ça a été
terrifiant pour un certain nombre
d'entre eux mais je leur dire une chose
ça n'avait jamais été fait ce qu'on a
fait parce que c'était le plus difficile
neuf joie mais s'il y avait eu service
minimum ça aurait été mieux apparemment
pas le service minimum s'appliquera à
partir du 1er janvier
on n'a pas à prendre les gens en otage
mais un gouvernement qui veut conduire
une politique de réforme doit dialoguer
et pour dialoguer il faut qu'il y ait
des partenaires et
des partenaires y compris ceux avec qui
dont je suis théoriquement le plus
éloignés ont pris leurs responsabilités
aujourd'hui les négociations lieu
j'espère que tout ceci conduira à ce que
les cheminots les électriciens et les
gaziers les agents de la ratp
comprendront que nous n'avons pas voulu
les humilier qui avait un travail à
faire je les fais mais je comprends
parfaitement par ailleurs qu'ils aient
des demandes sociales qu'ils aient des
problèmes que c'est pas facile la vie
pour eux comme pour tant d'autres en
revanche ceux qui ont cassé
ceux qui ont saboté ceux qui ont détruit
des éléments du service public étaient
très minoritaires
très mais ceux qui ont fait ça auront à
rendre compte devant la justice
vous aviez dit il y aura pas de
vainqueur et vaincu néanmoins le
gouvernement n'a pas reculer sur
l'essentiel
qu'est ce que vous pensez là quand même
qu'il ya une page qui s'est tournée par
rapport aux gouvernements précédents
vous n'avez pas céder sur les principes
dialogue mais on ne cède pas et pas de
recul même madame choc ça change
beaucoup de paysages pourquoi je dis que
je fais pas qui a vaincu rien vaincu
parce que moi j'ai été élu pour cinq ans
je suis président depuis six mois est
encore temps de travail à faire j'ai
encore tant de réformes à conduire
il ya encore tant de problèmes on attend
de moi des solutions
le but n'était pas de faire les régimes
spéciaux de sortir avec des syndicats
exemple un gouvernement prétendument
triomphant et qu'est ce qu'on fait après
on se regarde pendant quatre ans dix ans
j'ai gagné toi tu as perdu ce que
j'avais mais c'est pas comme ça qu'on
conduit un pays comme ça pied
moi je vais pas juger mes prédécesseurs
j'ai déjà bien assise à fait important
de l'enjeu ne pouvait pas reculer pas
parce que c'est l'intérêt national que
de conduire cette réforme mais l'intérêt
national s'est aussi gardée des
interlocuteurs ya encore quatre ans et
demi de réformes
je fais une première proposition ce soir
je proposerai aux partenaires sociaux
salariés comme patronne à l'organisation
à la mi-décembre d'une conférence
sociale que j'introduirai pour faire
ensemble l'agenda social de 2008
les grandes réformes que nous allons
mettre en oeuvre avec un seul but on dit
mais il faut redonner de la cohérence il
piquait quel est mon but c'est le plein
emploi n'avait vu les chiffres du
chômage vient de sortir vingt-trois
mille chômeurs de moins
vingt-trois mille chômeurs de moins pour
la première fois depuis 1982 on passe en
dessous de 2 millions de chômeurs c'est
encore beaucoup trop
moi j'ai promis le plein emploi et l'on
nous allons faire une grande conférence
sociale sur l'agenda social mais je vais
mettre des têtes de chapitres et je veux
qu'on en discute et c'est une véritable
révolution que je propose d'abord dans
un certain nombre d'entreprises
s'il ya un accord majoritaire accords
majoritaires entre le chef d'entreprise
et les syndicats et salariés
ils pourront s'exonérer des 35 heures en
échange d'augmentation de salaire je
veux sortir de l'atonie de la
négociation salariale dans les
entreprises en louisiane dans toutes les
patries porte à porte c'est simple quand
il n'y a pas d'accord ça sera avec 35,1
dans toutes les entreprises où les
partenaires sociaux négocient rond un
accord majoritaire
on échangera plus de travail contre plus
de salaire je vais te mettre sur la
table un autre sujet absolument
révolutionnaire
nous payons quelque chose comme 20
milliards d'allègements de charges et
c'est normal pour la compétitivité de
nos entreprises les branches
il n'y aura pas de négociations
salariales je remettrai en cause les
allègements de charges communisme
jusqu'au mondial et ça c'est conditionné
moi je veux sortir d'une situation
invraisemblable parlons du pouvoir
d'achat où le smig augmente pour 17 %
des salariés selon un calendrier qui n'a
rien à voir d'économique mais
exclusivement politique en général les
gouvernements l'augmentent quand il ya
des élections et où 83% des salariés
n'ont pas d'augmentation de salaire les
35 heures ont été payés de l'atonie de
la négociation salle rien mais je
mettrai aussi en débat la question du
travail le dimanche et avec l'ouverture
des magasins je veux que les salariés
qui veulent travailler le dimanche
puisque offert sur la base de l'accord
le volontariat qu'il soit payé le double
mais
on puisse élargir les possibilités de
travailler pour retrouver de la
croissance
j'ai été élu sur une conviction qu'il
fallait réhabiliter le travail me dis il
faut donner du pouvoir d'achat mais pour
donner du pouvoir d'achat il faut
réhabiliter le travail
il faut permettre plus de travail il
faut mieux le rémunérer
c'est ça la solution à savoir plus de 3
500 il ya pas d'argent à distribuer ce
qu'il attend de moi j'ai vu que le parti
socialiste avec beaucoup de sens de
l'humour prévoit un paquet dépenses
supplémentaires sans prévoir aucune
recette en face et dans le même temps me
dis que je ne vais pas assez vite pour
réduire les déficits à les recettes par
an qui propose on en s'en prennent un
peu aux compagnies pétrolières il faut
de gros traits vieillis mais on va en
voir venir là on va parler on sait
qu'avec vous pensez qu'avec ça il suffit
par ailleurs que les compagnies
pétrolières mettent leurs sièges
ailleurs il ya plus de recettes
la démagogie doit avoir des limites on
n'attend pas de moi quoi il ya déjà
plein de des visites est trop
d'endettement
la seule façon d'aller du pouvoir
d'achat c'est de créer les conditions de
la croissance est de réhabiliter
travaillé fait notre proposition pas les
35 heures est prévu des rtt que les
quantités de salariés qui accumule les
retraités sap lui confère des rtt
d'ailleurs moyennant quoi quand ils ont
alerté des moines travail eh bien je
propose la monétisation des rtt là qu'on
puisse rage c'est à dire que tous les
salariés qui se mettent d'accord avec le
chef d'entreprise puissent transformer
les jours de rtt en argent
ça représente 13,1 milliards il est
aussi notoire bachand puce alors on la
fonction publique
bien sûr qui a aucune raison de traiter
les fonctionnaires différement pour la
fonction publique j'ai dit autre chose
parce que je n'ignore rien du malaise de
des fonctionnaires qui ont un travail de
plus en plus dures parler de cette
enseignante vendée compte être traité
comme ça ça travaille très dur alors
pour les fonctionnaires d'abord joué une
mesure de justice est désormais les
heures supplémentaires seront payés pour
les fonctionnaires comme elles sont
payées dans privé
dans le privé les heures supplémentaires
c'est 25% de plus et bien aucune raison
que les fonctionnaires et des heures
supplémentaires qui parfois sont payés
moins chers que leur normale
deuxièmement les fonctionnaires pourront
monétiser pardon de cette expression
horaires télé rtt comme un bellier ce
qui est du pouvoir d'achat se faire
prier au lieu d'avoir ça puisqu'ils
donnent de la souplesse à
l'administration et à l'entreprise
je pense que c'est très important et par
ailleurs je demanderai dans la fonction
publique le premier ministre organise
des négociations pour régler cette
affaire du stock d'heures
supplémentaires qui n'ont pas été payés
dans l'hôpital comme dans
l'administration
ça ce sont des mesures très pratique
pour le pouvoir d'achat on voit pas se
supprime également les 35 heures puisque
mine de rien vous y arriver mais parce
que c'est la question pour moi n'est pas
de supprimer les 35 heures la question
pour moi c'est d'arriver au plein emploi
je ne veux pas revenir sur un acquis
social je me donnais aux français la
chance de travailler plus pour gagner
davantage mais je vais aller encore plus
loin parce que je pense qu'il ya un vrai
problème de coût de la vie qui se posent
les gens qui font leurs courses voit
parfaitement clavier augmenté beaucoup
plus vite que n'augmente leurs revenus
et leur ville contraire nous c'est la
raison pour laquelle je demande qu'on
crée un indice du pouvoir d'achat qu'ils
correspondent
enfin à la vitre qui viennent des
français nouvelles dépenses notamment
les biens et pour que les français aient
le sentiment qu'on ne se moque pas d'eux
et quand ils entendent cap une inflation
ou cas pas d'augmentation des prix qui
le constate dans les bacs du supermarché
et non pas qu'on leur raconte des
fariboles
on a tout intérêt à faire la vérité et à
faire la clarté sur cette question mais
je vais également engagé une grande
discussion avec la distribution car
aujourd'hui nous sommes dans un système
qui ne me convient pas les producteurs
et les petites entreprises ne sont pas
rémunérées au prix de leurs produits et
le consommateur ne retrouve pas les
efforts qui sont demandés aux
producteurs et donc je peux aller très
loin
indépendamment du texte qu'elle a fait
voter à l'assemblée monsieur chatel sur
la négociabilité je vais aller très loin
pour qu'on obtienne la baisse des prix
dont nos grandes surfaces
l'écho des communes était au budget vous
le demandiez déjà il vous
guy louis et puis finalement bien de se
dépasser monsieur pandore pardon
tendance était pas au budget et ministre
des finances à l'époque c'est en 2004 on
a eu 3 25% de baisse des prix alors
c'est d'autant plus nécessaire qu on a
en plus la hausse des matières premières
mais pendant qu'on y est je pense
également un autre poste de dépense des
français qu'est le logement et sur le
logement du proposait deux changements
importants et qui donneront du pouvoir
d'achat immédiatement d'abord quand vous
êtes locataire
ça m'a toujours frappé on vous index vos
loyers sur l' indice des prix à la
construction comme les matières pacte
mais comme les matières premières
augmentent le prix des loyers a augmenté
beaucoup plus que les revenus des
locataires
eh bien je demande que l'indexation ne
se fasse plus sur l' indice des prix à
la construction mais l' indice des prix
tout court sur la place sur ce qui
permettra de diviser par deux
l'indexation et la hausse
enfin je posais la remarque d'un jeune
couple quand il prend un appartement il
doit payer le premier - n'avance il doit
payer deux mois de garantie est les
trois mois et il doit en plus fournir
bien souvent une caution j'ai demandé au
premier ministre a mis du logement de
conduire des négociations pour que
d'abord au lieu de deux mois de garantie
ce soit plus qu'à moi et deuxièmement je
souhaite qu'on ne demande pas de caution
qu'on fasse une mutualisation publics
qui permettent de ne pas demander un
quotient tout ceci ce sont des mesures
extrêmement concrètes qui pourraient
rentrer en vigueur
quel moment mais qui vont entrer en
vigueur dès le début d'année enfin je
pense qu'il faut débloquer les fonds de
participation un plafond sera déterminée
peu importe 10000 euros je crois pour
qu'on puisse ça représente quand même 12
milliards d'euros
c'est pas dans tout est dans les six
mois qui viennent mais j'y vais venir
dans les six mois qui viennent pour
remettre du carburant dans la croissance
française et du pouvoir d'achat dans les
entreprises de moins de 50 salariés
comme vous le dites très bien il n'y a
pas deux
participation est bien dans ces
entreprises je souhaite que toutes les
entreprises qui donnerait une prime à
leurs salariés puisque a pas de
participation ça puisse être
défiscalisés de cotisations sociales
vous voyez ce que j'essaie de faire
c'est de redonner du carburant à la
croissance française depuis que je suis
élu il y avait eu 92 mille chômeurs de
moins par dire c'est pas grâce à vous
peut-être ici en avait eu 92 milles de
plus on dirait c'est à cause de vous
donc je peux pas être celui qui perd la
bataille quand la bataille progresse pas
être celui qui l'a fait progresser
je veux réhabiliter le travail et
répondent de cette façon au problème du
pouvoir d'achat des est-ce qu'on peut
décréter tout seul la croissance au
milieu d'un environnement international
et à chaque fois j'ai vous ne l'avez dit
la dernière fois d'ailleurs j'irai
chercher le point de croissance
supplémentaire est recherchée mais vous
n'êtes pas seuls convenait dans un
environnement international un peu
compliqué et en même temps vous
m'interrogez une heure après la
publication d'indicés deuxième mois
consécutif où la france diminuent le
nombre de ses chômeurs de plus de 20000
23000 ce mois ci si on était resté les
bras croisés moi je me souviens de la
polémique au mois de juillet quand le
texte les mesures fiscales ont été votés
mondiaux la la quelle erreur il fait une
politique du pouvoir d'achat alors qu'il
faudrait faire une politique de l'offre
sur la compétitivité des entreprises
voilà trois mois après en branle me
reproche au contraire elles ont été
utiles ces mesures fiscales oui elles
ont été utiles et je vais m'en expliquer
je vois la dizaine de baigneurs comme un
boulet le paquet fiscal avait on dit
c'est terrible il a mangé toutes ses
marges de manoeuvre
le président et le gouvernement imaginé
faire cadeau aux riches alors plastique
et je ne sais pas je ne sais pas ça
c'est un encore fumantes le fini oui
bien sûr avec difficulté d'ailleurs je
crois que c'est un argument très bonne
foi qu'est ce qu'on a fait avec ses
dizaines de milliards mobilisés
j'ai voulu qu'on puisse donner davantage
d'heures supplémentaires on dit ça
marche pas mais c'est invraisemblable le
texte sur les heures supplémentaires
s'appliquent depuis le 1er octobre
mais laissez nous un peu inégal j'y
viens depuis le 1er octobre ça
s'applique
nous sommes au mois de novembre vous
pensez de spécialistes qui peuvent en un
mois et demi jugé que ça marche ça
marche pas il ya 900 millions d'heures
supplémentaires
ces cinq milliards d'euros qui ont été
données aux salariés et ceux qui font le
plus d'heures supplémentaires
c'est les ouvriers et salariés les plus
modestes est-ce que ça c'est un cadeau
aux riches et puis 2 milliards et demi
que nous avons mis pour quoi faire pour
que tous ceux qui achètent un logement
puisse déduire jusqu'à 40 % des intérêts
d'emprunt ce un cadeau aux riches ne pas
être obligé de payer des impôts sur les
intérêts qu'on verse à sa banque
mais au nom de quoi c'est un cadeau aux
riches et puis j'ai mis un peu d'argent
également pour que toutes les
successions moyennes et modestes soient
exonérées d'impôt sur les successions
c'est un cadeau aux riches quand on a
travaillé toute sa vie de devoir rendre
plus payer un impôt parce qu'on laisse à
ses enfants
le produit d'une vie de travail à bord
on n'a pas la même conception cléry je
sais qu'en son temps monsieur hollande
avait dit qu'il n'aimait pas les riches
il est fixé à se gagner plus de 3000
euros par mois et doit passer mis
lui-même alors non mais quand même il ya
un minimum me semble-t-il de bonne foi
avoir et c'est en train de marcher alors
bien sûr qu'on s'est pris et c'est pas
une bonne surprise
la crise des subprimes sûrement pas
prédéterminé écoutez la hausse du
pétrole c'est extraordinaire quand
j'étais ministre finances en 2004 le
baril de pétrole était à 42 dollars
il est à près de 100
la baisse du yen l'euro qui monte à 1
dollar guy brun de un pas pratiquement
quasiment oui exactement
un dollar et demi mais monsieur
beauregard bord ces difficultés la cij
avait pas eu celle ci je n'aurai d'autre
et toute manière on n'a pas eu pour dire
écoute exclusive bras ya des problèmes
aux états unis je peux rien faire il ya
des problèmes en chine il faut rien
faire
je reviens de chine on ramène pour
l'industrie française
20 milliards d'euros de contrats mais ça
c'est du travail pour nos usines
parce que moi j'ai promis que je ne
laisserai pas tomber les usines dans
notre pays je pars en algérie je vais
ramener encore des contrats pour aider
nos usines
parce que le rôle du président de la
république c'est d'être derrière les
entrepreneurs de france c'est de les
aider c'est d'aller chercher la
croissance
au maroc deux milliards de contrats pour
les entreprises dont le tgv le premier
tgv dans un pays musulman
donc je me bat sur tous les fronts pour
faire les réformes en france avec les
partenaires sociaux pour qu'on soit plus
compétitif pour revaloriser réhabiliter
le travail pour avoir plus de croissance
et donc moins de chômeurs mais qu'est ce
qu'on attendait de moi qu'est ce qu'il
fallait face d'autres de surcroît on
investit dans l'université dans la
recherche
nous allons mettre un milliard d'euros
de plus chaque année pendant cinq ans
sur le budget de l'université mais joue
à lens autre chose nous allons vendre 3
% d'une 3% d'une grande entreprise
publique française edf pour faire un
plan d'investissement de 5 milliards
dans nos universités pour doter nos
universités des plus beaux campus pour
que les étudiants puissent travailler
dans dans des locaux dignes de ce nom
pour avoir des logements dans les cités
universitaires c'est pas possible qu'on
continue comme ça on a fait voter la loi
sur l'autonomie des universités nous
voulons les meilleures universités du
monde en france voilà ce qu'on essaye de
faire le tour en six mois d'abord c'est
une curieuse conception que ça consiste
à faire grève quand on est étudiant peut
être mécontents enfin théoriquement on
fait pas grève dans l'adversité c'est
pas prévu en tout cas de
droit de grève n'est pas tu n'as pas bon
pas son contentement a toujours existé
le mais ça c'est autre chose mais quand
on aime on peut exister bien sûr mais
enfin blanc qui n'ont pas compris la
réforme en m a dit non enfin je suis pas
sûr que ceux qui ont bloqué d'abord la
notion de blocage est parfaitement
inadmissible et je généraliserait la
question du vote à bulletin secret une
minorité n'a pas bloqué on doit laisser
les étudiants étudier et les salariés
travaillaient ce sont des méthodes dans
notre pays
ça n'existe une par ailleurs est tout à
fait normal qu'un étudiant on peut être
en désaccord et que gouvernance et la
démocratie
on peut être en désaccord avec un projet
un texte mais de là à empêcher les
autres de venir travailler
ça prouve qu'on n'est pas tellement sûr
de ses idées l'autonomie des universités
qui a été votée au mois de juillet mais
c'est un texte qui fait confiance à
l'université toutes les universités dans
le monde qui ont réussi sont diversité
qui ont à donner de l'autonomie
j'entendais par l'autre l'autre jour à
la télévision
quelqu'un qui sert aux il veut
privatiser universités jeu privatiser
universités on met un milliard d'euros
de plus au budget diversité et de la
recherche
ça ne s'est jamais produit dans
l'histoire de la république et jeunes a
lancé 5 milliards de plus de travaux
pour investir dans nos universités
mais si on voulait les privatiser on
ferait pas sa vérité c'est celle d'ap
politiques dont passe d'ailleurs ce
qu'elle a de plus noble et plus
intelligent nous voulons les meilleures
universités pour la france je veux des
conditions de travail pour les étudiants
qui soit bien meilleure et puis madame
chabot moi j'ai été élu pour ça quand
même
j'ai été élu pour changer les choses
pour trouver les solutions aux problèmes
de la france pas pour les commenter
alors bien sûr le derby vous avez des
difficultés monsieur ah oui mais je
regarde ça les gordon brown a des
difficultés
angela merkel a des difficultés toutes
les personnes qui essayent de faire des
choses ont des difficultés évidemment je
crois même qu'on va les accélérer et
voilà confère au repos avant de parler
vous en à l'entrée d'autres réformes
bien sûr je veux qu'on travaille sur
quelque chose qui me tient très à coeur
de quelqu'un que premier ministre il a
bien raison
comment se fait-il que la législation
sociale française vous en parliez vous
même tout à l'heure soit la plus
complexe et théoriquement la plus
protectrice et que les salariés ne
soient jamais senti un tel état de
précarité et que les chefs d'entreprise
ne soit jamais senti aussi contraint je
veux qu'on sorte de cela comment peut-on
faire et ça sera l'un des objets de cet
agenda social que je vais négocier avec
les partenaires sociaux
comment on peut faire pour donner
davantage de flexibilité aux entreprises
et en même temps donner davantage de
garanties aux salariés c'est la
sécurisation des parcours professionnels
qu'une femme ou un homme de 45 ans qui
se trouve au chômage elles droit à la
formation qu'on laisse pas tomber qu'on
puisse généraliser le contrat de
transition professionnelle kb
l'expérimenté jean louis borloo qui
permet vous savez un un salarié licencié
pour des raisons économiques de ne pas
être chômage d'avoir un contrat avec
l'état d'avoir une nouvelle formation
pour trouver un nouvel emploi c'est ça
qu'on va négocier avec les partenaires
sociaux
j'ai conscience que ce champ des
changements considérables mais je
demande aux français de réfléchir à ça
même dizaine de pays en europe qui ont
plein emploi panneaux
comment ça se fait on a avec les 35
heures choisi de travailler moins
vous l'avez payé de votre pouvoir
d'achat je ne veux plus qu'on mettre les
gens dehors à 52 cents à 53 ans alors
dans le même temps leur dis de cotiser
plus longtemps pour l'arbre est
important c'est ce qui se passe encore
d'un endroit et bien c'est pas un ego si
ce n'est pas ce n'est pas acceptable
je ne veux plus que les jeunes est en
difficulté à trouver des emplois non mon
rôle c'est de porter les changements
pour qu'on fasse aussi bien que les
autres
il n'y a pas de fatalité à l'échec j'ai
été élu pour cela
écoutez je sais où je vais je les dis
aux français je veux le faire avec
beaucoup de détermination le chameau
tranquillement mais je ne renoncerai pas
je ne reculerai pas jamais le président
sarkozy se dit nicolas sarkozy candidat
a fait un peu trop de promesses gérard
du mal
tenir alors interrogé mois sur les
promesses que je ne pourrais pas tenir
non je manque c'est vous qui regardez
vous dit bon je fais vous dites pas là
j'ai pas bien mesuré la difficulté même
chabot j'ai beaucoup réfléchi à mon
projet de campagne
j'ai pris tous les risques dans le débat
qui nous a occupés avec madame royal
j'avais dit que je ferai la réforme des
régimes spéciaux et je savais
parfaitement que cela détournerait de
moi des cheminots les électriciens des
gaziers je les dis j'ai dit que je ne
ferai pas la ratification du traité
simplifié par le référendum
j'ai tenu j'ai indiqué qu'il fallait
travailler plus pour gagner plus vous
savez je ne suis pas venu à l'élection
présidentielle comme un écervelé
c'est un choix de vie c'est beaucoup de
deux peines
enfin beaucoup de peine au sens un de
lourdeur la vie d'un président de la
république et passionnante mais les
lourdes
je n'ai pas fait ça au hasard j'ai
beaucoup travaillé et vient de ce que
j'ai fait depuis six mois
en effet et comme ça d'une lubie le
matin quand je me lève j'ai la
responsabilité d'un pays à conduire j'ai
pas le droit de me tromper mais ça peut
m'arriver comme tout le monde dans ce
cas là je m'en explique
mais quand je dis je veux pas céder
c'est pas une question d'ego président
public n'a pas à voir des gosses ça
serait parfaitement inadmissible quand
je dis on va faire d'autres efforts mais
je vous en donne des exemples d exemple
lors très lourd mais c'est parce que je
crois que c'est l'intérêt de la france
de le faire si je veux justement être à
la hauteur des promesses que j'ai fait
aux français quand je rends hommage aux
aux partenaires sociaux
c'est pas une habileté c'est parce que
je ne peux pas réformer tout seul je
sais parfaitement qu'il faut des
partenaires qu'il faut qu'on discute
la fermeté nécessaire le dialogue aussi
et c'est ça que j'essaie de faire cinq
grands pays la france voyez les
syndicats plus fort avec une
représentativité plus reconnue c'est
d'ailleurs un des sujets que je mettrai
dans l'agenda social aussi très lourd
mais je crois qu'ils foutent tout faire
en même temps parce que il ya une
cohérence je me pose le problème du
critère de représentativité
côté lancé oui mais la dernière fois
qu'on a parlé des critères de
représentativité c'était 1966 et avancer
1945 on peut peut-être qu'ils
interrogeaient aujourd'hui je veux
parler du financement
la moitié seulement des recettes des
syndicats sont les cotisations sommes le
seul pays en europe où c'est comme ça je
vous parle vous choque ce qui est
amusant c'est qu'on passe mon temps à me
demander de garantir l'indépendance de
la justice ne pas m'en mêler
et à chaque étape on me demande sur des
affaires en cours ce que j'en pense en
tant que président un public
je n'ai pas pensé quelque chose de ces
affaires-là j'observe c'est un problème
je veux revivifier le dialogue social
je posais la question des accords
d'entreprise on fond pourquoi la loi
empêcherait tel dans une entreprise des
salariés et un chef d'entreprise de se
mettre d'accord et à quelles conditions
peut faire un accord majoritaire et
c'est une grande avancée pour les
syndicats cette notion d'accord
majoritaire
je dis aux français il faut pas que vous
soyez inquiet de toutes ces réformes que
je porte ce qui devrait vous inquiétez
sexy que je ne faisais des réformes que
dans un coin parce que je déséquilibre
le reste de la société française la
société française doit avancer à la même
vitesse
je dois faire du quinquennat que vous
m'avez confié un quinquennat utile pour
le pays
vous avez des problèmes dans les
banlieues vous avez un problème de
chômage
vous avez un problème de pouvoir d'achat
vous avez un problème d'éducation ya un
problème d'autorité dans le pays est un
problème d'intégration et d'immigration
je ne peux pas dire écoutez la première
année je m'occupe de l'emploi puis je
m'occupe pas de la formation
la deuxième année je m'occupe de la
formation mais je me plie pas du social
il ya problème des retraites ya problème
de l'assurance maladie
j'ai des problèmes de l'hôpital il ya
problème de la formation professionnelle
que je mettrai dans cet agenda social
franchement la formation professionnelle
et le marche bien pour celui qui en a
pas besoin
c'est à dire vous avez fait hec vous
avez envie de faire l'insee had vous
trouvez certainement un grand groupe
pour vous financez en revanche vous êtes
dans le textile votre boîte ferme n'est
pas de quoi apprendre un nouveau métier
c'est ça que je veux changer
on parlait tout à l'heure de problèmes
judiciaires prédécesseur est poursuivi
pour des faits
il remonte à longtemps est ce que vous
pensez qu'il doit siéger encore au
procès les cautionner
il est présumé innocent comme n'importe
quel justiciable je n'ai pas de
commentaire à faire
si c'est que c'est toujours dommage que
la justice vient de sita sur l'algérie
vous allez partir il eu des propos plus
qu'étonnant de la part d'un ministre du
président bouteflika qui parlait de
l'homélie et de lobby juif qui vous a
incité à demander carrément la
repentance pour tous les crimes du
colonialisme entre guillemets
qu'est ce que vous allez des jeunes en
mouvement le président bouteflika au
téléphone cet après midi il m'indiquait
ce sont ces mots que ce qui avait été
dit de refléter en rien la position de
l'algérie
je lui dis que je combattrai toute mes
forces l'antisémitisme l'islamophobie et
toute forme de racisme
je considère qu'on ainsi dans
l'écloserie j'irai en amis en algérie
pour quelque chose soit tout à fait
clair sur l'agenda social et la réunion
vous allez tenir il ya il ya un délai
c'est à dire que l'agenda social 2008
la première réunion qui va ce lien si
j'ai bien compris à l'elysée devra avoir
la nuée à la vie à la sueur gagnent et à
la mi décembre et on fera avec les
organisations patronales et syndicales
l'agenda social sur la mi 2008 on le
fera ensemble laurière de grenade ce que
les termes l'expression est à la mode
enfin les lignes de l'agenda social
depuis que l'airé nous l'avons fait pour
le grenelle de l'environnement a marché
non mais c'est un agenda social mais ce
que les français je voudrais qu'ils
comprennent c'est que je comprends leur
inquiétude eu le sentiment de précarité
parfois même l'exaspération et leur
demande de croire une chose j'essaie de
prendre tous les problèmes à bras le
corps pour y apporter des solutions
je ne veux en évité aucun je leur
rendrai des comptes à eau pour lui dire
mais enfin si ça marche pas si ça marche
tant mieux si ça marche pas pas le
gouvernement prendra ses responsabilités
et déposera des textes
c'est ma conception du dialogue social
mais c'est plus possible de continuer en
disant voilà il ya un problème en le
commentant fait rien je ne peux pas moi
même décidé d'une augmentation générale
des salaires dans les entreprises
je peux en revanche dire négociés ou les
allègements de charges seront
conditionnés et je peux dire
les 35 heures ont tout bloqué si vous
mettez d'accord dans l'entreprise
salariés chefs d'entreprise alors vous
pouvez vous en exonérer voilà ce que je
veux faire voilà la méthode que je
propose écoutez ça pas si mal marché
pour les régimes spéciaux pour le talus
minutes vers cité pour la fusion anpe
unedic ben on va continuer et on
continuera à voir le président de la
république allait voir les pêcheurs en
colère au guilvinec président de la
république allait récupérer des
journalistes qui ont été arrêtés au
tchad on verra aussi un président quand
il ya un conflit qui s'annonce avec les
régimes spéciaux face à des grévistes à
la sncf le président sur tous les fronts
dans un gîte à respectivement
d'expliquer par ce que j'ai vu qu'il y
avait des interrogations le temps
démocratie c'est normal pourquoi j'étais
au guilvinec
c'était pas commode je m'attendais pas à
être accueilli avec des vivats
j'étais au guilvinec parce que j'ai
estimé que c'était le rôle du chef de
l'état d'aller voir des pêcheurs qui est
en train de mourir parce que la pêche
française c'est comme l'agriculture
française où l'industrie française c'est
identitaire c'est une question
d'identité nationale et j'ai pas
l'intention de laisser ces gens mourir
et ils mourraient pour des régions
arlette chabot n'était pour rien compte
tenu du prix du fioul dans le bateau et
donc j'ai estimé que c'était mon devoir
d'y aller n'était pas très commode
notre avis que michel barnier en deux
jours n'a dénouer la crise parce que je
n'accepte pas qu'un pays qui bordent
l'atlantique la manche et la
méditerranée
on laisse notre pêche à la dérive la
sncf comme la ratp
moi j'ai été les voir parce que j'ai
trouvé que c'était profondément anormal
qu aucun président de la république a
été les voir alors que l'actionnaire
propriétaire c'est l'état et je suis le
chef de l'état là non plus ce n'était
pas facile mais je voulais leur dire que
je ne tenais pas les humilier que je
comprenais leur problème
je n'aime pas les la caricature qu'on
fait d'eux par moments c'était une façon
de les convaincre
mais qu'est ce qu'on attend de moi que
je reste enfermé dans ce palais
j'observe d'ailleurs que sur les six
mois pendant cinq mois et demi on a dit
que j'en faisais trop
et voilà pendant les grèves je n'ai pas
parlé pendant huit jours
pas du tout mais parler pour quoi faire
alors que les trains étaient bloqués
j'ai beaucoup discuté et j'ai beaucoup
parlé mais justement je restais en
réserve au cas où il y aurait un
problème parce que c'est toute
l'ambiguïté la difficulté de la tâche
d'un président de la république vème
république
il doit être à la fois le moteur du
changement et larbitre doit être les
deux celui qui impulsent l'énergie
nécessaire pour porter les changements
il pour apporter les solutions et en
même temps celui qui l arbitre pour
équilibrer par exemple recevoir les
familles de ces deux jeunes
c'était mon devoir c'était mon devoir
pour montrer à chacun ben que sa douleur
été prises en compte
il ya beaucoup de victimes à france dans
tous les domaines alors bas c'est mon
devoir il ya beaucoup de travail
oui mais moi je ne je ne pense pas que
mon rôle c'est d'être uniquement dans
les sommets internationaux
il me désintéressais ce qui se passe ici
et puis je vous dire autre chose
je suis comme ça hein j'ai été élu pour
faire un travail j'ai envie de le faire
j'ai envie de le faire pleinement j'ai
envie de le faire complètement
totalement
je pense que il faut pas s'économiser
qu'il faut pas être à barres de ses
sentiments de son énergie
j'ai une place passionnante
j'ai un rôle lourd mais j'en suis
heureux je je n'ai pas à me plaindre
parce que je sais que la vie quotidienne
des français et beaucoup plus à plaindre
que la mienne si on l'essentiel de notre
rencontre ce soir c'est évidemment le
pouvoir d'achat avec beaucoup d'attentes
on l'a dit des français à votre avis les
français nous tiens ça change pour moi
quel horizon à votre avis mais tout de
suite je comprend des moyens en terme
d'argent on est très bon cru mais est ce
que les gens attendent et entretien de
soi
c'est tout tu l'as dit vous savez les
gens sont beaucoup plus régionale
prendre les machines je ne pense pas
qu'ils attendent qu'il soit 6 ou qui
pensent qu'il suffit qu'un président
dise quelque chose pour tout change pour
eux mais ils exigent une chose c'est
qu'on se mette au travail tout de suite
je pense qu'à deux divisions pour les
français la première c'est que j'ai
l'honnêteté alors qu'ils ont voté pour
moi en tout cas majoritairement et je
suis président même de ceux qui n'ont
pas voté pour moi
est-ce que d'ici est ce qu il a
l'honnêteté de reconnaître que le
problème qu'elles notent un vrai
problème
donc j j'ai regardé de très près ce
qu'elle fait monsieur jospin époque sur
le sentiment d'insécurité
non c'est pas un sentiment est une
réalité qui a pas un sentiment
d'exaspération et du pouvoir d'achat
bien problème de pointe est-ce qu'il
prend en compte notre problème premier
de choses et deuxième chose est ce qui
s'y attaquent vraiment après les
résultats on verra mais est-il s'attaque
vraiment voilà l'objectif qui est le
mien que vous avez foncé s'attendent pas
que je distribue les cadeaux de père
noël qu'ils savent parfaitement bien
qu'à pas l'argent dans les caisses
la seule façon de répondre à cette
question c'est de permettre aux gens de
travailler plus et gagner plus
la france n'est pas en faillite non
votre premier ministre avait par exemple
sur ce point on en a parlé ensemble
il a raison de dire qu'il n'a pas
l'argent le premier ministre avait
parfois eu l'idée de ces choses et il
n'y a pas de problème entre le premier
ministre les ministres et moi on fait
une équipe
on travaille dur vous savez quand et où
ces événements villiers de bain et
michèle alliot marie et françois fillon
dans tout de suite appelé par la
question du décalage horaire je note
ce doit être mobilisable 24 heures sur
je savais parfaitement ce qu'ils
faisaient ils l'ont très bien fait et
quand je suis arrivé à michel
m'attendait et on était ensemble
l'hôpital
c'est une équipe alors c'est vrai que
moi je pense que le chef c'est pas suite
ils se mettent derrière il qu'ils
laissent les autres prend des copies
diable voilà c'était pas ma faute c'est
l honneur moi mon tempérament c'est
plutôt de me mettre devant parce que si
les choses ne vont pas je suis le
premier responsable du fai
même pas voilà c'est la fin de cet
entretien les on approche dès 21h merci
de nous l'avoir accordé non merci de
m'avoir invité
[Musique]